so anyway to knock around just sand by
game pie my reputation has been
tarnished oh no what the hell that was
not like that before
why this is not the way that it was
before
give me yon dairy coming through hey can
you tell stand by never mind
mmm you smell fresh come here let me
sniff your crotch you're not said bye
how about you I'm not weird
you're always for not doing it this way
so what happens if I just straight up
blam oh no they didn't suspect a thing
oh hi senpai house I'm just taking out
the trash
yeah alright don't mind me
huh yeah Oh activate oh okay that makes
more sense see I did not know that I
thought I thought that you know maybe
maybe you would have done it by itself
hi ho hi ho after my blonde I go
doo-doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo senpai
don't notice me right now someone needs
to stop spilling so much hair
around here it's not aired I love that
boy I actually have no idea what I'm
supposed to be doing so I'm going to do
a thing
hello bonk oh no someone killed her oh
my goodness I have no idea
weirdest thing Oh God Oh Oh visibly
insane okay well this is not good
whoa warning warning
whoa this uh this isn't any kind of good
Wow holy crap Wow
and they're twitching why I'm twitching
the plan kind of went awry the only
little bits maybe this Sam's and Bible
that is really creepy by the way that is
really creepy oh my god this is so
cinematic and disturbing
and even weirder like this Oh
senpai will
ever know haha so awesome wait a minute
I just wanted to commemorate this moment
and see just how creepy this can be I
guess once I go full yandere yon dear
yandere you don't go back you never go
fully under a theory Oh God boobs
McKenzie just stop pushing around a
little bit okay finally time to start
cleaning up the blood whooping whooping
whooping ooh whoo whoo for the murder
weapon just check that on in there like
yeah let me just finish up with the
bloody blue hi-ho hi-ho it's off to work
we go by well it senpai to notice me
okay
and change of clothes whoops stop the
[ __ ] change clothes
that's like murder never happened except
for all those missing students Oh can't
cry over spilt eggs
oh god no okay I don't think there's a
safe mechanism in here let's go say hi
descend pie-holes n pi where are you I'm
coming for you senpai oh do you be
afraid of me boys tonight
he's a senpai oh gosh even in the
darkest even in the my darkest of times
I still love so you didn't see anything
did you
whoa who dared who dared to leave these
footprints I did did not good thing I
checked what is this it why is this
happening squiggly Scooby Doo why did I
have a few more bloody footprints there
never happen never never ever never
happened it did not hit her I did not I
did not kill them I didn't know oh yeah
I forgot I'm visibly insane whoopsie
better stay away from senpai then little
better let myself calm down a little bit
okay goodbye everybody
I'm sure it's all hunky-dory
hehehe okay goodbye
and areas approached by teacher
exhibited extremely erratic behaviors
brightening the teacher the teacher
becomes angry with the Andheri chen but
she is able to return home without
further incident goes to sleep who has a
nightmare about losing senpai if won't
happened oh gosh oh gosh you know I
killed everyone for you it's kind of
like we're falling in love down this way
oh my goodness oh my gosh oh my gosh
you're so cute
Oh guys let me sniff the name of your
neck sometime sometime creepin on you
cuz I'm creepy creeping on you cuz I
love you creepin on you cause you D
prettiest and pinehold it's like I'm
kissing you
except I'm shoving my face into your
skull that's what loves about okay John
Barry Jana's eliminate failed to
eliminate a rival before Friday evening
what what there was no other rival Oh
was the orange haired girl the rival no
damn it man Fraggle and pop oh but I
didn't even think I couldn't she wasn't
doing anything oh I killed everybody
except the one that mad
well see about that you come here you
yeah marry rival [ __ ] how dare you I
can't even do anything to her oh this is
[ __ ] oh come on you know how crazy I
am I'll kill everyone okay so that's the
undara simulator I really don't know if
there's anything left for me to do I
actually played it for a while because
it was kind of fun but I don't know what
else I'm supposed to be doing so as I
wait for the cops to come haul me away
from my horrendous murders thank you
everybody so much for watching and for
suggesting this game if there's ever an
update to it or if I missed something
very very important let me know in the
comments down below thanks again
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
big hug oh how did I snap here you know
nice nap doing something oh god not of
the murder but of you know disturbing
senpai okay I'm out what do try new
things I'm changing